you're telling it wrong each other then  [Applause]  Islanders the bond you have with your  partner's about to be truly tested in  today's game bound by love gone by lasse  you can never leave me a couple gold a  shoe rack we couldn't use our middle  hands go to look at the way they're  doing it we're not doing it tomorrow at  all so it was a little bit difficult if  they probably work together instead of  actually built a shoe rack by myself  before and I'm impressed  I know maybe you should let me take the  lead in turn acts like macho man and we  would have been finished I'll try my  forearm just still hurts  [Applause]  hey cash do you know who this is  dude I was so nervous calling you right  now I was like at least we live in the  same place and I don't know maybe in the  outside world we can see what happens  how about right now what's my booty  gonna do that hey I actually cannot do  you feel me shaking and I made a video  and I just I couldn't wait  you